it's a weekend and John decided to watch
the latest movie recommended by Netflix
at his friend's place
before heading out he asked Siri about
the weather and realized it would rain
so he decided to take his Tesla for the
long journey and switched to autopilot
on the highway
after coming home from the eventful day
he started wondering how technology has
made his life easy
he did some research on the internet and
found out that Netflix Siri and Tesla
are all using AI
so what is AI
AI or artificial intelligence is nothing
but making computers-based machines
think and act like humans artificial
intelligence is not a new term John
McCarthy a computer scientist coined the
term artificial intelligence back in
1956 but it took time to evolve as it
demanded heavy computing power
artificial intelligence is not confined
to just movie recommendations and
virtual assistants
broadly classifying there are three
types of AI artificial narrow
intelligence also called weak AI is the
stage where machines can perform a
specific task Netflix Siri chat Bots
spatial recommendation systems are all
examples of artificial narrow
intelligence
next up we have artificial general
intelligence referred to as an
intelligent agent's capacity to
comprehend or pick up any intellectual
skill that a human can
we are halfway in a successfully
implementing this space IBM's Watson
supercomputer and gpt3 fall under this
category and lastly artificial super
intelligence
it is the stage where machines surpass
human intelligence you might have seen
this in movies and imagined how the
world would be if machines occupied
fascinated by this John did more
research and found out that machine
learning deep learning and natural
language processing are all connected
with artificial intelligence
machine learning a subset of AI is the
process of automating and enhancing how
computers learn from their experiences
without human health
machine learning can be used in email
spam detection medical diagnosis Etc
deep learning can be considered a subset
of machine learning it is a field that
is based on learning and improving on
its own by examining computer algorithms
while machine learning uses simpler
Concepts deep learning works with
artificial neural networks which are
designed to imitate the human brain this
technology can be applied in face
recognition speech recognition and many
more applications natural language
processing popularly known as NLP can be
defined as the ability of machines to
learn human language and translate it
chat Bots fall under this category
artificial intelligence is advancing in
every crucial field like healthcare
education robotics banking e-commerce
and the list goes on like in healthcare
AI is used to identify diseases helping
healthcare service providers and their
patients make better treatment and
lifestyle decisions
coming to the education sector AI is
helping teachers automate grading
organizing and facilitating parent
Guardian conversations
in robotics ai-powered robots employ
real-time updates to detect obstructions
in their path and instantaneously design
their routes artificial intelligence
provides Advanced data analytics that is
transforming banking by reducing fraud
and enhancing compliance
with this growing demand for AI more and
more Industries are looking for AI
Engineers who can help them develop
intelligent systems and offer them
lucrative salaries going north of one
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
future of AI looks promising with the AI
Market expected to reach 190 billion
dollars by 2025.
so on that note I have a question for
you
artificial intelligence is about playing
a computer game creating a device using
your own intelligence to program an
intelligent machine investing your brain
power in a machine
give the correct answer along with your
reasoning and stand a chance to win an
Amazon voucher think about it and leave
your answers in the comments section and
we will provide the answer next week
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
Channel and click on the Bell icon for
more on the latest Technologies and
Trends thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from Simply learn
[Music]